tnews in montana was always very high i
mean marijuana was ubiquitous in montana
it still is medical marijuana didn't
change it it didn't change the culture
of montana at its core hi i'm anthony
fisher for recent TV and I'm sitting
with Rebecca Richmond Cohen the
filmmaker behind the new documentary
code of the West Rebecca thanks for
talking with us thanks for having me can
you briefly describe the plot of co2 the
West so we set out to make a film about
the legislative process in Montana and
we wanted to follow the public debate
over medical marijuana laws medical
marijuana was legalized in 2004 in
Montana and it was a quiet small program
and then in about 2010 it became very
visible very quickly and because many
communities in Montana didn't even have
the power to create basic zoning laws
flashy dispensaries some opened
kitty-corner from junior high schools
with advertising that looked like it was
targeted children now the interesting
thing is that by a study that was
designed by the Centers for Disease
Control so the federal government it
showed that teen use actually decreased
by every measure steadily since 2004
when Montana first legalized so the
people who are organizing the repeal
movement stood up in front of the state
legislature and made claims that teen
use had increased fourfold and this
information was simply not correct I
think there was a lot of fear I think
there was a lot of misinformation and
the opposition picked up on it the fear
and misinformation was fueled in no
small part by statewide raids that were
conducted by the federal government can
you describe what the code of the West
that is the title of your film what does
that refer to
so the code of the West was another bill
that we followed through the Montana
State Legislature and it was a bill that
would codify the cowboy code of ethics
as the official state code of ethics and
we thought it was a great metaphor about
the sort of anxiety that was also
revealed in the medical marijuana debate
and anxiety that was really about the
identity of Montana and it seemed like
both the people who were pushing to
repeal the medical marijuana law and the
people who were pushing to codify the
cowboy code of ethics had some sort of
nostalgia for a past that was really
imagined and never existed tnews and
Monty
was always very high I mean marijuana
was ubiquitous in Montana it still is
medical marijuana didn't change it it
didn't change the culture of Montana at
its core so there were all these very
strange and superficial debates that
seemed to miss what was really going on
you know as filmmakers it was a great
gift to make to make a film in Montana
where we could really make a character
out of the landscape and this gave us a
sort of lyrical way to explore this
metaphor speaking of characters the
former governor of Montana who's
depicted in your film taking a branding
iron to represent his veto of the
medical marijuana repeal bill can you
talk a little bit about him yeah the
state legislature moved to repeal the
medical marijuana law and Governor Brian
Schweitzer moved to protect the will of
the people and veto to the repeal
literally with a hot stove and a
branding iron on the front steps of the
State Capitol
and it's these these sorts of moments as
a documentarian when you think wow you
know I actually couldn't have scripted
this reality is stranger than fiction
sometimes and so he's a Democratic
governor in a largely Republican state
and he was very popular at the time he
left office was his veto popular so it
depends on how you ask the question
Montanans were very frustrated with the
implementation of the medical marijuana
law and so if you asked the question to
most Montanans would you rather keep the
law as it is a repeal it most Montanans
would in fact have said we prefer repeal
now if you rephrase the question and
said would you prefer regulations and
reform and keeping the medical marijuana
program versus repeal then a much larger
percentage seventy something percent of
Montanans would have would have
preferred just to fix the law where does
the issue stand now yeah well in some
ways we made a strange film about an
outlier state most states are moving
forward in implementing sensible
marijuana policy reforms Montana was one
state that moved backwards but it's also
a really important story to tell and I
think in many ways even more important
to tell now because there's a way to do
this wrong and there's a way to do this
better and one of the wonderful things
about allowing States to be the
laboratories of experimentation is to
figure out what we can learn from the
states that have done it well from
states like New Mexico and Maine where
patients do have access to medical
marijuana
yet there isn't an intense backlash and
also to consider that the federal
government at any moment could come in
and shut this whole experiment down and
that the Obama administration hasn't
been responsive about their plans for
responding to the legalization efforts
in Washington and Colorado and I think
it's very telling that two years ago the
Obama administration spoke out against
the legalization effort in California
yet this November they said nothing
about the the votes in Washington and
Colorado and I think it's also equally
telling that more people in Colorado
voted for marijuana than they voted for
Barack Obama and so I think it's a real
opportunity for the administration to
re-examine our draconian drug policies
their failures and to think through a
more sensible way to govern this thank
you so much Rebecca Richmond : the film
is ko to the West for reason TV i'm
anthony fisher